hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this piece of land and are
prototyping another way of living
and in the previous update i show you a
tour of the land what it looks like
and in this update i'm going to show you
something i wasn't aware of before
buying this land let me show you outside
hey welcome to the second update
of the land um so one big thing i
learned this week is that it actually
rains quite a lot around here i mean we
knew it would rain more in the north of
portugal in the south but i thought man
it's portugal how much can it really
rain
but yeah apparently quite a lot i can
show you later um
but yeah in a way it's good because
everything is very green and everything
grows a lot of life
but i guess for human conditions it's a
bit less fun when it rains
especially if you're just in a van but
one thing i wanted to show you guys is
what it does to roads
so for instance here you have a road
and the road accumulates the water so it
creates these little streams
but it actually also the water it erodes
the roads so it makes this
really big holes in here
and this is still a tiny one if you see
over here
it's much deeper
yeah really big grooves but because of
that
you can't really drive this road anymore
but we kind of have to drive this one
because we have two shipping containers
on a big truck
having to access this so yeah we need to
find a way to make this
flat and that it fits besides all the
trees
there so yeah this is going to be one of
the missions to clean this
road but now i'm thinking because last
time
we've been here on the land it was
summer and there was a little stream
downstairs and it had some water
which is cool that's still in the middle
of summer had that water
but i'm curious now it rained a lot to
see
if it got better or more or increase
the weather so let's have a look
so here's the little creek and it's not
even that much fuller
even though it rains all the time i
wonder how the water goes
probably on my head it's time to get in
so this is basically how i get home now
wet socks all the time
i did find a very good drying method
it is with a magnet magnet
and then you just hang
your clothes to dry
perfect
okay so the rain is not necessarily a
big problem i guess i just didn't see it
coming i always learned that
netherlands you go for rain portugal you
go for the sun
so i was looking up a little bit i mean
how much does it actually rain
and i found this quite interesting chart
it's from a website that gathers the
rain from the last
40 years all right so let me show you
here in these diagrams
the weather in the netherlands and here
the region in portugal
and then here you have all the months
and then maximum temperature minimum
and the amount of rain there falls in
millimeter
so let's say january right now you would
have
175 millimeter of rain in portugal
and in the netherlands you would have
just 70 millimeter
which is less than half so if we go to
for instance
november netherlands 85
and and here it would be 135
so way more the only months where it's
really different is here in the high
season so let's say you take august it's
only 50 millimeter in portugal
and in the netherlands it would be 65
but overall the amounts of rain in
portugal
is much higher than over a year than in
the netherlands
so yeah didn't see that coming yeah i
see what you're thinking maybe
you should look this up dave before you
buy land uh
to see the climate because you're gonna
make quite an investment and you're
gonna spend quite some
years of your life in there uh i agree
it makes sense to look this up i guess
we just assumed
in the portugal it would never be that
much rain
but uh yeah i think it will be okay but
i'm just at this point also just not
really prepared
i mean this van is like a humid cold
sauna
i don't really have any rain gear with
me and the only thing i can really be
is in this van because if i go outside
it gets wet even drying clothes it's
hard because
i mean it's not really that much less
humid in here
so yeah it's time to make a few changes
and upgrades
upgrade one i saw from a local guy who
was walking around like that yesterday
so i'm gonna give it a try so basically
on his feet he was wearing some
dry socks but on top of that you put a
plastic back
so your socks don't get wet
doesn't sound like a super good approach
but i mean
better than having wet socks every day
so
let's see
yeah this kind of looks like how he was
walking around
upgrade number two is installing a bit
of a shelter
because now the only dry place is inside
so we're going to set up a tarp on the
outside
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
so that's two good upgrades let me see
if the other one is good
no i still got wet socks
[Applause]
maybe the back is broken nope
boat's still wet one good upgrade
upgrade
[Applause]
all right so that was the second update
if you'd like to see these updates and
want to see all of them make sure to
look here
if you like to follow this in general
make sure to subscribe because we're
going to have way more updates coming in
the future we're just getting started
and if you want to make sure we can
really turn this place into something
beautiful
and really dive into all the details
make sure to visit
support.projectcom.com
thanks for watching and see you in the
next update